christena botas kitchen is a hub of
activity she has invited her friends
over for a demonstration of the
all-singing all-dancing thermomix a
sales rep has come to explain how to use
the versatile kitchen appliance let me
just briefly explain the importance of
these three digital dials Elish tiding
sells Thermomix appliances for the
manufacturer for Veck christina Berta's
daughter isn't so keen on the
presentation so her father will be
looking after her tonight Torsten Bota
is quite impressed with the 1,300 euro
device as a man who can cook I think
it's super
I can easily conjure up great dishes
with it now for some Irby cream cheese
the mixer tells you what ingredients to
put in then works on its own for a while
the appliance does all the kneading and
mixing so I can do other things tidy up
a bit and set the table that's efficient
and saves time but it doesn't replace
Christina's other kitchen appliances of
course I still bake things in the oven
and cook my steak in the frying pan
so our cookbooks a thing of the past
never throw away my cookery books
we'll stop using them because I love
looking at the pictures I like leafing
through them like magazines we've just
seen that the Thermomix display tells
you what to do next it might even be
good if you're prone to forgetfulness
for men
and the device cut vegetables in
medium-sized pieces so they remain
looking decorative first of all we'll
show you how to make a broccoli salad
and then you can tell me if you still
have a problem okay
broccoli salad with pine nuts looks good
the broccoli is perfectly chopped
sensors in the device keep it from
getting smashed up for verax appliance
isn't available in stores only from
sales reps like Gabriella hiding for vac
is based in Beaufort all in western
Germany it had total sales of 3.4
billion euros last year 1.4 billion just
from the Thermomix division an analogue
version of the appliance has been around
for 30 years but the introduction of a
digital version sent sales rocketing in
the first few months we had a big
backlog it took up to 12 weeks for
delivery and in Germany alone turnover
doubled in this time thermomix devices
are produced in Germany and also France
the appliances second biggest market
German pump head of R&D at four Varrick
is one of the company's 150 engineers
many imitators are trying to bring out
cheaper versions so it's important that
the appliance should retain its
competitive edge the moment we bring out
a device we have to start considering
what the next model will be like what
new functions that should have
the company also offers recipes online
they're available to customers on their
website for a fee they can be viewed
directly on the appliances touchscreen
by a Wi-Fi we can see which recipes are
especially popular perhaps there will be
seasonal recipes then we can offer
special packages during the year so in a
way you've also become a software
company yes exactly
digital content is growing it's a
business sector that offers a lot of
opportunity in Hamburg the cooking
demonstration is still underway and the
rep is still hoping for another sale the
cookie lies that the cookie is little
with the cookie you can download all
your favorite recipes directly from the
cookie do portal onto the display of
your Thermomix the women still have
their reservations have to think twice
before spending that kind of money the
appliance finishes the main course in 30
minutes even if they decide not to buy
the device the friends have had lots of
time to catch up and eat thanks to the
automated cook in the kitchen
man or woman against machine we staged
our very own kitchen jewel on social
media a business presenter Gerhard
edifice as the traditional
do-it-yourself cook versus the Thermomix
enthusiast janelda Milan now financial
correspondent in this snippet Jenelle
describes the automated experience as
heaps more relaxed Gerhard insists he
beat the machine okay so first part of
the challenge quick up the human well
that's not necessarily true because I
got to do other things in the mean time
it wasn't about speed it was about what
else he could do was about concentration
those are the benefits of this you see
the cooking time is the same it's 40
minutes i defined the cooking time
myself i finished when it's finished